نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد منذ بدء الهجوم
الروسي على اوكرانيا سارع الغرب بفرض
عقوبات على موسكو شملت قطعه عده منها قطاع
المال والطاقه ومجالات عده شملت حتى
الثقافه والرياضه العقوبات الغربيه
ركزت على الحد من تمويل العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه وذلك باستهداف قطاع الطاقه وعزل
روسيا عن النظام المالي العالمي ومنع
تفوقها عسكريا الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض تسع
حزم من العقوبات تستهدفت القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين وحظر اجوائه على الطائرات
الروسيه كما فرض حظرا على تصدير تكنولوجيا
المتقدمه بما في ذلك المعدات العسكريه في
خطوات نسقها مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكندا ودول اخرى في قطاع الطاقه
ركزت العقوبات الغربيه على تقليص قدره
روسيا على جني ارباح من بيع النفط وكان
ابرز تلك الضغوط زيت سقف سعري للنفط
الخامه الروسي بنحو 60 دولار للبرميل الا
ان العقوبات لم تحقق نجاح المطلوب بحسب
مراقبينك اشاروا الى تراجع الاقتصاد
الروسي العام الماضي ولكن ليس بقدر
التوقعات نناقش هذا الموضوع وهذا الجزء
الثالث من موضوعنا عن ذكرى ذكرى الاولى
للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه مع ضيوفنا من
موسكو بسام البنيه الكاتبه السياسي اهلا
بك
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم
ضيوف الكرام اسمح لي ان ابدا معك استاذ
بسام استاذ بسام موسكو اساسا دخلت هذه
الحرب عليها عقوبات سابقه
واتت هذه الحرب بعقوبات جديده
تسع مراحل عقابيه سلطها الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك واشنطن على روسيا هل اثقلت كاهلها
هل اتعبتها وباي شكل هل هو بشكل المنتظر
ام لا
اسعد الله اوقاتك استاذتي الكريمه واستاذ
ادمون مساؤك الخير ومساء مشاهدين قناه
العربيه الكرام طبعا بكل تاكيد الاقتصاد
الروسي تاثر كما تاثرت الاقتصادات الاخرى
في العالم ولكن اذا اردنا ان نبحث عن
الخاسر والرابح في هذه العقوبات فسنجد انه
في المدى المنظور
الخاسر هو روسيا والعالم والاتحاد
الاوروبي بينما الرابح الوحيد هو الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اما اذا ما نظرنا على
على المدى الطويل فالخائر الخاسر الوحيد
هو الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والرابح الاكبر هي روسيا وبقيه
الدول العالم لان اولا هذه العمليه
العسكريه اجملت روسيا على استخدام السلاح
الذي يستخدم لمره واحده وهو سلاح
السويفت وسلاح مصادره الاموال الروسيه بين
قوسين سرقه الاموال الروسيه فسرقه الاموال
الروسيه اع لدول العالم باننا لا نستطيع
ان ناتمن على المنظومه العالميه
للاقتصاديه التي تديرها امريكا للعلم
روسيا كانت منذ تسعينيات القرن الماضي تحت
العباءه الامريكيه حتى في زمن بوتين في
العشر سنوات الاولى من حكمه من حكمه كانت
امريكا تتحكم بجزء كبير من مفاصل الدوله
اخرها كان
المدرسه الاقتصاديه العليا والتي اشار
اليها الرئيس بوتين في خطابه امام الجمعيه
الفيدراليه حيث قال انه يجب اعاده تعليم
الى المرحله السابقه قبل التسعينيات الى
التعليم الاساسي السوفيتي الذي لا يعتمد
على الليبراليه وعلى
يعني الطريقه التي يتعامل فيها وهنا هناك
حديث في موسكو ان هذه المدرسه نصفها من
الطابور الخامس يعني حتى دكاتره الجامعه
بها هذا يعني اننا نحن امام تطور نحو
الاستقلال الاقتصادي والاستقلال السياسي
هذا الشيء سيؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى كسب
روسيا وبقيه انحاء العالم التي تسعى نحو
السياده الاقتصاديه وخساره الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اقتصاديا لانها
وانسرقت الان مئات المليارات من الدولارات
من روسيا ولكنها خسرت الثقه الموروثه من
بعض الحرب العالميه الثانيه ما يعني اننا
سنشهد تدهورا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عاجلا ام اجرا ولكن حاليا تتحدث
وتقول بان المستفيده الاكبر هو واشنطن على
حساب اوروبا وهذا ملفت وهذا حضرتك ونحن
نواكب هذه الحرب وعلى حساب روسيا ولكن هي
على حساب روسيا يعني يقول
المعلق بانه يعني
مش مهم لهالموضوع ولكن على حساب اوروبا
حليفها فهنا النقطه الملفته دكتور اضماط
ما رايك في هذا الكلام الم تفكر واشنطن
الم تقرا حساب من تعتبره ومن تقول بانه
حليفه في هذه الحرب وحليف الاقتصادي كذلك
في العموم
فعلا تحياتي لك
والاستاذ البني بدون شك ان
هذه العقوبات هي مؤلمه وهي مؤلمه لروسيا
هناك اخبار طبعا تصل الى العالم الخارجي
الى اوروبا بان هناك مشاكل مثلا بارتفاع
اولا كلفه الكثير من المنتوجات
والسلع قد تكون ارتفعت اثمانها او بعضها
ليست على المستوى المطلوبه لانها كانت
رديئه هذه قد تتراوح من امور تتعلق ببعض
الاغذيه الى اجهزه منزليه الى كمبيوتر
وغير ذلك ولكن هل هذا يعني بان روسيا قد
اصيبت بالشلل او قد انهارت كما كان يتوقع
القاده الغربيين وعلى راسهم الولايات
المتحده فان ذلك لم يحدث الروس نجحوا في
فتح
اسواق جديده ودول كثيره
بدات تتعامل معهم ربما كانت في البدايه
دول مثلا مثل تركيا التي باعت اسلحه الى
اوكرانيا في نفس الوقت فتحت ابواب كثيره
لبيع منتوجات تركيا وغير تركيا لروسيا
وجدت مخارج ولكن تتفق مع ضيفي بان هذه
العقوبات اضعف الدخل الاوروبي وهنا السؤال
سالته سابقا وساطرح سالته سابقا على طيله
هذه السنه التي نتابع فيها التطورات ولكن
ساعيد طرحه الدكتور ادم هل تعتقد بان
واشنطن تعمدت كذلك اضعاف اوروبا من خلال
دفعها الى طرح هذه العقوبات التي اضرت بها
فيما بعد
لا اريد ان اقول
تعمد تضعف اوروبا ولكنها تعمدت ان تعتمد
اوروبا اكثر واكثر على الولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بعدد من المنتوجات من الطاقه
مثلا الغاز او النفط
وارادت تقليص الاعتماد على روسيا ومن هذه
الناحيه يمكن القول بان الولايات المتحده
قد حققت فعلا هذه الاهداف على الاقل حتى
الان ولكن هناك ايضا تبعيات وبدانا نراها
مثلا التقرير الذي نشره
او الذي تحدث عن تدمير الخط نور
وايضا الحق اضرار واحد هذه النصف الثمن
لهذا الخط دفعته المانيا المانيا هي واحده
من اقرب الحلفاء
للولايات المتحده وبالتالي فعلا اذا كان
هناك الان دعوات للتحقيق من هو فعلا امل
مجلس الامن وهذه ستكون مؤلمه على المدى
البعيد
الاوروبي ليس حتى الان القيادات الاوروبيه
لا تزال مستمرا اسمع بان عقوبات جديده
قادمه
ولكن دكتور ادمان هم فشلوا اليوم كان هناك
تصريح لياتي من الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول بان
الاتحاد الاوروبي فشل في تثبيت او في
تسليط حزمه عاشره من العقوبات على روسيا
وهنا سؤال استاذ بسام هكذا خبر فشل
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الاتفاق على حزمه
عاشره
يوحي بشيء يوحي بتوتر العلاقات الاوروبيه
الاوروبيه والاوروبيه الامريكيه تعتقد
يعني بكل تاكيد هناك خلافات في الاتحاد
الاوروبي بين بينيه وهناك خلافات بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فقد كانت اوروبا تعتقد انها
مدعوه الى الغداء فاستكثرشف انها هي
الغداء نفسه هذه نقطه النقطه الاخرى دعيني
اذكر بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عندما كان الكساد الكبير في بدايه القرن
العشرين خرجت من ازمتها الاقتصاديه من
خلال الحرب في اوروبا اليوم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديها
يعني عجز اقتصادي ولديها ازمه اقتصاديه
تتاثر في كل الكره الارضيه تريد الخروج
منه على حساب توريد الغاز المسال الى
اوروبا ورفع نفقات التسليح في اوروبا يعني
خلقوا لهم البعبع الروسي من اجل ان
يبيعوهم الاسلحه ويرفعوا نفقات التسليح
ازدهار اوروبا كان يعتمد على شيء وعلى
اشياء سلاسه الطاقه الرخيصه من روسيا
والانفاق المينيموم
السلاح
واليد العامل الرخيصه للصينيه بعد هذه
العمليه العسكريه خسروا كل شيء لذلك انا
لديها فائض
ان اسمع منكم نقطه كنا بدانا بها هذه
الحلقه ولكن لاهميتها الصين تقترح حل
ستطرحه غدا على واشنطن لكلاكما ابدا معك
دكتور ادماد هل تعتقد بان الحل سياتي من
الصين نعم ام لا
لا اعتقد ان الحل الان قادم من الصين
لاننا لا نزال بعيدين عن اي حل حقيقي ولكن
لا اعتقد ان هناك حل سيتم
تنفيذها سنه انتظر لنفهم هذا المقترح
سنتابع هذا الموضوع اود شكرا جزيل الشكر
من موسكو بسام البني الكاتب السياسي ومن
واشنطن غريب الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
واعذران على ضيق الوقت وغدا ستكون تغطيه
خاصه لهذه الذكرة شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا بهذا نصل الى نهايه بانوراما
لهذا المساء خصصناها لعشيه الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه شكرا على
طب المتابعه والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]